hey guys Pete here I'm gonna do
something different today because for
the past two days I've been working on
and doing the slowest tree watch in my
life and it's become clear that breaking
down the last two parts of the return
isn't the most pressing thing on my mind
spoiler warning real quick don't watch
this if you haven't finished season
three of Twin Peaks the return yet it'll
crush any chance you have I'm enjoying
the ride for yourself but before you
click away think about following the
link that I just put above in the right
hand corner because you can learn about
a book giveaway I have going on through
my patreon account okay
is that let's do the details and think
about the past three months of watching
this show there are a few things that
keep coming back up so this will be a
bit more personal than my other Twin
Peaks videos usually I like to show all
the stuff that happened and then we talk
about it this is more about my personal
feelings about the experience of
watching it I imagine that some people
won't enjoy this they won't find it
enjoyable just as many people didn't
find the finale enjoyable and that's
okay because at the end of the day anger
frustration disappointment bewilderment
or any other kind of feelings you
experience they're your own you know
it's it's not really my intention to
change your mind
when I did my initial recap I mentioned
I was stunned I had experienced a range
of emotions while watching the finale
and overall thought that was a good
thing did the show end in the way I
dreamed it might no did I expect that to
actually happen though
not really so there's that my
expectations weren't dashed I was
completely mesmerized at what I was
watching and since then I haven't
stopped thinking about it those are all
good things I you know Bravo but the
video I wanted to make today is why I
think the finale of Twin Peaks the
return was great and those are just part
of it I've been reading through the
comments both good and bad and absorbing
the different points of views that
people are throwing out there one thing
we can all agree on I think is that
there is very few there are very few
people who are in the middle of the road
they're just like casually
I'm affected by the last two hours of
Twin Peaks in reality people have been
moved to a variety of different emotions
and it actually reminds me of how we got
here in the first place I've read a few
I guess you would call think pieces or
whatever people that have more education
than me call them and they bring up the
idea how masterfully they had changed
the question of how zani
into the question of what year is this
you know in other words that we're going
to wonder the answer to that question
for decades to come and this is
interesting since there was only a brief
reference to an e by hawk and because of
that there was surely no resolution to
that big question of how is an e that's
been there for the last 25 years my take
on the whole thing is slightly different
though and I believe I am in the right
demographic to be able to make this
observation what I've been thinking
about the past few days is why did we
like this show so much in the first
place
why did the question about Annie or what
was going on above the convenience store
or just insert whichever unanswered
question you might have had like stuck
in your mind why did those things stick
in our minds what was the nostalgia that
brought us back to it really about
because actually things were left in a
pretty unsatisfying manner I'm one of
those few people that loved fire walk
with me the first time I watched it but
I have to tell you there weren't many of
us and in retrospect the reason most
people disliked it was precisely for the
reason that a lot of people disliked the
ending of season three fire walk with me
didn't answer their questions it didn't
really answer many questions it's been
all this time in a shitty town called
Deer meadow where all the people were
definitely jerks instead of being quirky
and lovable like the people in Twin
Peaks it was dark and it was scary and
perhaps most importantly there was no
Audrey and almost no Dale Cooper but
still here we are and we all watched and
we all build up our expectations and we
all experienced something that left most
of us feeling like we needed some time
to process how we felt so these are the
reasons it worked for me and the reasons
why I have no qualms about saying that
it was a great great saying and probably
the most memorable TV event that will
stick with me until the days where I
just can't watch TV anymore mind you
this is all subjective and I could
blather on about art and the experience
of the viewer but whatever it's just my
tape it's just the way that I decide to
look at it
Twin Peaks season 3 up to and including
the final two episodes were great
because of the relationship we have with
nostalgia growing old and the fact we
absolutely cannot go back in time to
change things
Audrey's unresolved storyline is
probably the greatest example of this
but let's talk about some of the warm
and fuzzy stuff first big Edie getting
with Norma finally and dr. Jacoby and
Nadine let's get something straight
these people are not young they're not
in the prime of their life anymore Peggy
Lipton and Everett McGill or both 71
years old Russ Tamblyn is the eldest at
82 and then we have the youngster Wendy
Roby who's only a mere 63 years old the
scenes these actors shared were the most
heartwarming ones we saw but there's a
lot more to it you know it's not boy
falls in love boy chases girl in the end
the boy gets the girl and they live
happily ever after it's really
interesting if you think of the
backstories the big Edie and Nadine
problem is obvious since we know all too
well that their love for each other has
been enduring over all these years in a
situation where they couldn't act on it
we saw just how painful that was when we
watched Edie
eating his soup in the credits scene
where the same car goes by at the time
we were all looking for some
supernatural event or explanation of why
we were watching him but in reality we
were just looking at his life he wasn't
at home he wasn't happy or enjoying his
life he was just sitting at his place of
business after hours eating soup and
trying to hang
in there was a giant stuffed bear head
on his desk dr. Jacoby or dr. amp if you
will turned out to be pretty interesting
we learned that he became a grumpy
conspiracy theorist kind of guy after
the state took away his license to
practice medicine as a result of his
unconventional methods every time we saw
him he was a reminder of all the anger
that people turned outward when they
can't make sense of the way things
turned out in their own lives then in a
really great moment he runs into Nadine
and we see that he's still human as much
as a [ __ ] bag as he's apparently become
we got the sense that there might still
be time for him to turn it around and we
saw that his golden shovels that he's
shilling just to make a living actually
played an important part in Eadie and
Norma getting together the idea of
nostalgia sort of comes up for me when I
think about James Bobbie and Audrey
unlike the hero of twin peak season 3
which I personally think was called Rod
I'll have to look into that a little bit
more in a different video
these three were the coolest of the cool
back in 1989 we were even reminded that
an awkward moment when Shelley goes out
of her way to point out the fact that
James was always cool to her friends
when the truth didn't really quite seem
to match up with that James the former
emo bad boy with the motorcycle
currently works as a security guard he
seems to have a crappy shift and he
still goes to the same bar he did when
he was 17 years old Bobby on the other
hand transformed himself from a
drug-dealing murderer into what appears
to be a pretty upstanding citizen but
despite that it never equated to his
life turning out all right his daughter
who we saw he legitimately cared for
probably ended up getting killed by her
abusive husband and his ex-wife Shelley
is dating the local drug kingpin whether
she knows it or not and Audrey if you're
about my age or older you remember
seeing Audrey's image everywhere when
the Twin Peaks hysteria was full-blown I
mean she was big like it was I don't
know how you could explain it now I
guess she would be all over social
Media back then you know there were
stores that sold posters and in the
front of those like there was always one
of Audrey because she was hot
pretty much every man alive at that time
would be lying if they said they didn't
find her attractive and most would just
change the word attractive with
something a little more extreme but you
get what I mean she was kind of like the
pin-up girl or like the brunette version
of Marilyn Monroe
she was it and now well we don't really
know something not good is going on with
the Audrey of season three Audrey
situation is a little more abstract than
these other guys but at the very least
we can agree that things didn't work out
for her she had everything going for her
when she walked into the bank which that
should have been a harmless situation
she was trying to make a point there
shouldn't have been a bomb or any of
that but instead of walking back out of
there something unforeseen happen and
the bank explosion wasn't an isolated
event since we know that somehow she
ended up giving birth to Richard and we
saw how that turned out in a way this is
all relatable though I think we all have
those things we wish we could go back
and change or the things that we
second-guess or the decisions that we if
we just maybe would have thought about
it a little bit longer our entire lives
might have turned out a different way
it's part of being human and it's a part
of growing old we all live inside a
dream because we all have dreams and at
that very same moment more often than
not our lives don't reflect what we
dream them to be and I'm not talking
about this as like a gloom and doom kind
of you can't get what you want reality
it's just it's just something that we
all have inside of us I think the most
successful people in the world
experience it just the same as the
people who are most down on their luck
we are the dreamer because life is a
continuing line that leads to death we
fill our time thinking about TV shows we
watched 25 years ago holding out hope
that we finally get the right conclusion
the characters and Twin Peaks are the
dreamer and Big Ed and Norma paid for
that kiss with pain that comes
from having a human heart years of pain
Audrey's life looked like a dream all
those years ago but it appears to have
been a never-ending nightmare ever since
James looks ridiculous playing his song
on stage 25 years later but when he was
a young guy with a bunch of prospects of
being something important it takes on a
whole different context
I imagine that people will continue to
compare all of this with the American
Dream or the theory that Laura is the
dreamer who made all this up in her mind
as a way with the of dealing with her
trauma or that it's Audrey's dream or
whatever and those are fine
interpretations don't get me wrong but
when I think about the story coming up
with something that makes sense seems a
lot less important instead of looking at
the question of who is the dreamer as a
catalyst to us taking the deeper look
and solving the case I've been thinking
about it as an open ending question
about our existence a question that we
can all ask ourselves and a question
that connects us in our love of
nostalgia our fear of growing old and
our desire to fix things or solve the
puzzle so that life will somehow seem
more purposeful again this is just my
take but it does bring us to our beloved
Agent Dale Cooper Cooper's a character
here with a long history of dreams and a
deep concern for their significance I
don't need to tell you guys about that
here but he is the one who said to
Philip Jeffries phrase in part 17 we
live inside a dream actually it wasn't
exactly him it was an image of his face
that was superimposed over the screen
from the time he and Diane looked at the
clock where it was stuck at 2:53 it had
been there earlier when he saw Nadeau
after the brouhaha that led to Bob's
demise but it disappears as they're
sharing their kiss then it comes back
and as he takes Diane's arm and turns to
the gang that are all assembled in Frank
Truman's office the superimposed Dale
says we live inside a dream and then the
real Dale says I hope I see
you all again and then the key thing
happens he gets to do something that no
one else ever gets to do nevermind that
he leaves behind all these people that
he hasn't seen for 25 years he has a
purpose and it's to go back in time and
to fix something that he doesn't want to
happen and now this is a very simplified
way of looking at it and I get the idea
that this is bigger than just stale
himself because we're talking about the
mother of all evil in an eternal clash
with the firemen and all that other
stuff I mean I'm not I'm just not it's
not important to this part of my
interpretation so Dale gets to do what
we've always wanted to do he goes back
in time and he fixes something that he
thinks is wrong but instead of being a
tale about victory or triumph or the
good guy finally was saving the day it
turns into a cautionary tale because it
doesn't turn out to change anything
really for the better
Judy's force isn't removed from the
equation and in the end it seems that
agent Cooper is stuck in an eternal loop
of trying again and in that process he's
clearly lost a part of himself
and even though we don't know where
things are gonna go after that closing
scene if you really loved the original
Dale Cooper in the original series you
have to ask yourself the question of was
it all worth it so those are my thoughts
I could go on longer I do I feel
responsible to go and make those videos
like I have been all through the season
and I'm gonna do that
so I just wanted to put this out because
I know a lot of people are just sort of
like not knowing how they feel and I
don't know that's my that's the where I
landed so far it's not an answer but it
is food for thought and that's sort of
why we're here isn't it we've all been
thinking about these questions for so
long so now we have a whole new set of
things to talk about please like the
video if you enjoyed it make sure you
tell me in the comments what you think
it is a subjective experience and there
are no wrong ways to feel about this you
could think I'm completely wrong and
that's okay
because it doesn't make me wrong and
like I said I do have a book giveaway
going on over at my patreon account I'm
really excited to see how the final
dossier gives us a little added context
all of what happened at the end and I
can't wait til it comes out on October
31st so for those of you guys who join
me over there and you can you know any
small donation make sure you remember
I'll wait until the 31st and whoever is
on my role at that time I'll put all the
names and a random picker and we'll come
up with the winner and I'll send you the
book directly to your home so make sure
you subscribe if you haven't already
follow me on twitter and my other social
media accounts so we can talk over there
thanks for watching guys I'll talk to
you soon